I just saw a video.
You know, I love watching your Instagrams.
And there was a video that you posted that was beautiful.
And it was you and your mo
sitting at the headstone of your grandparents in Hawaii
and singing this beautiful song.
But your mom played great ukulele.
And I go, "Wait. What?!"
I did not know that she could play --
Your mom plays the ukulele
-Oh, yes. She is -- She --
Get my mom really quickly an tell her to bring the ukulele.
It's right there on the inside of the door.
-What? Does she -- -Mom!
No. Get the ukulele. -Okay. Got it.
-Is your mom there?
-She's right here. Here. Come here.
Okay. Good. Put that down.
-Yeah. -Okay. Come here. Come here.
I want you to say hello to somebody you know.
-Who? Ohh! -It's Jimmy Fallon.
-Hi! Oh, my gosh! Mom, you're gorgeous!
So good -- Good to see you
-Do you remember me? -Are you kidd--
From our bit. New Year's. Happy New Year.
I remember our bit.
-I know. I know. Do you remember what you did
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, I remember laying -
I remember laying on the groun pretending I was passed out.
-I know. -We were holding empty --
-That was awesome.
-We were holding empty bottles of champagne.
Oh, you were so funny. -We had the best time.
-That was the best.
-Lauren's mom and I, we ha the best time that night.
-Dude. And she constantly -- -We didn't expect you.
We didn't know you were goin to be there with your wife
-She called me. "Jimmy's here, and we're doing this!"
I was like, "Okay, Ma. Tell him I said hello.
But come on. Don't bother him. Don't bother Jimmy."
-We had so much fun. -I said, "Okay, I won't."
-No, no.
Honestly, seriously, Dwayne, your mom was fantastic.
She was so -- -We had a good time.
-We had the best time. But I just want --
I was just talking about you playing the ukulele.
Did not know that you played the ukulele.
Obviously, how would I guess this?
-He was asking -- When we went to visit Grandma and Grandpa -
-Oh, did you see that? -It was the most beautiful -
-I told him that -- -Every time we come to Hawaii,
we go up to visit my parents, yeah.
-It was beautiful. -She has -- Let's --
-I have mu ukulele. -I know.
-Let's sing him a song real quick. Go ahead.
-Okay, okay, okay. I got a song.
♪♪♪♪
-Oh. Sure. Okay. -Okay.
♪♪ Savalivali means go for a walk ♪♪
♪♪ Tautalatala means too much talk ♪♪
♪♪ Alofa ia te oe means I love you ♪♪
♪♪ Take it easy, faifai lemu
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness! Come on! Are you joking me?!
-We have one more. -No, we don't have one more!
what do you mean, we have one more?
What is this? What's happening
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ We love you, Jimmy, oh, yes, we do ♪♪
-Okay. I'll go with it.
♪♪ We love you, Jimmy, and that is true ♪♪
♪♪ When we're away from you
♪♪ We're blue ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, Jimmy, we love you
-Oh, my! I love you! -Good job, Mom. Good job.
-I'm sending love right back to you.
Mom just crushed, by the way
You just stole the interview You're unbelievable.
You are a superstar. -I love when she goes --
I love when she goes, "We got one more!"
I'm like, "What? We do?" "We love you, Jimmy!"
-That was unbelievable. -Good to see you, Jimmy.
-You're gorgeous. It's great to see you.
And, yeah, happy new year again. Let's do it again.
Guys, come on back.
We have more "Tonight Show when we come back.
Come on. We're going to talk "Young Rock."
-Say hi to your lovely wife. -I will.
-Leave, Ma! -Okay.
-[ Laughter ] -Mwah!